um
how did uh the show stop record come
together with the kendrick uh
we call them ad-libs yeah kind of like
ad-libs yeah yeah
yeah cause that was like uh shout out
rock i kind of took his swag on that i
saw a wind going crazy i was like i need
some i need some ad-libs man right right
right right right right yeah by the way
yeah shout out to
but no like how did uh like did you just
grab those vocals
from like a session or did he come in
and do it
nah because yeah that sounded like the
the the the record from um
the the the black panther soundtrack
with travis was it off of that uh not
the ideas were birthed though from that
and when it was birthed from those
records and uh i had showstopper already
and we were already talking about it
being a single and i was trying to get a
verse i'm not gonna lie
zach of course like i'm gonna swing for
the fences i was trying to get a verse
um but i started to slowly realize in
the conversation that ad-libs are more
reasonable you know what i'm saying and
uh it's funny because fans be giving me
slack they'd be like oh kendrick's
oh he just did the atlas i'm like [ __ ]
it took me six months to get these ad
libs like y'all better
enjoy these ad-libs like it took me a
long time to get
those ad-libs from dot you know what i
mean like to a point to where i thought
they weren't coming
um and it's funny because even when he
did the ad-libs he did a whole track of
them
and i still like were like taking some
and plugging them in different places
and stuff like that
because he hit me and he was like you
know like i did the ad-libs but it feels
a little crowded
and then when i sent him the record back
you know we plugged him in certain
places he was like
okay cool that feels more natural or
whatever because he even when he sent
him to me he didn't really like how it
sounded so he wasn't gonna
want it to come out that way you know
what i mean and so i had to rearrange
him and make it feel like a record and
then uh you know he gave me his blessing
on it but yeah shout out to doc
yeah it's crazy because you would think
like coming to tde like
i feel like fans expect you to just get
the automatic kendrick record
yeah yeah i don't feel like that's
happened for a while man like they think
it's like that's what i'm telling like
y'all thinking it hasn't been like that
for a very long time they think it's
like a td castle you walk in and then
you just get records from everybody i'm
like yo you want the q feature you want
like it was hard to get the cue if
you're picking off a [ __ ] menu or
something bro like it's q record is
crazy though yeah thank you did he make
you play golf with him first
he did not make me play i'm glad he
didn't because i'm horrible in golf but
uh
nah um that was actually one of the ones
that uh my manager came
uh he also managed his q and so he
pitched it to him and uh but
i didn't i wasn't sure if he was going
to do it you know what i mean but uh he
came through and he killed that [ __ ]
though
i [ __ ] with q man because q will all
like it don't matter
if you're major like if he [ __ ] with
you like he'll do the verse
exactly and if he's like in that
headspace like i like q because
it's like that one thing if he [ __ ]
with you he'll do the verse and then
also like
if q is working like he's working and
you know
like you'll have like i remember i had i
was listening to like like
burner styles p album and that fool was
on there and i'm like man that's why
accused the realest cause he'll tap in
with whoever
like i know him and freddie got some
[ __ ] on the way that i just heard that's
crazy
i'm already knowing that's probably
crazy super crazy but i need to give
freddy or some [ __ ] shout out to freddie
freddie is hard bro we'll make it happen
man
yeah no a thousand i definitely need to
do that